so can you walk me through what
typically happens during one of these
satanic rituals
um and
i'm i've heard you talk about it on
sean's
podcast why are these people
attracted to corpses
they believe especially if the cops is
not
being a cops for a very long time
they believe that they can get the
power and energy from the corpse
that is still residual
in the columns get it for themselves
by for example having sex with the cops
uh even maybe cannibalizing the cops
but sex with corpses is part of their
sexual practices because
the satanist attitude to sex could be
summed up with two words anything goes
so if they want to um
have sex with bodies as jimmy savile did
by the way
he was yeah he was a volunteer uh
so-called volunteer
porter at a hospital
known as leeds general infirmary up in
northern england
and he used his access to the mortuary
to have
sex with some of the corpses to
position the corpses before they had
rigor martyrs
and they were still quite flexible
in sexual positions i didn't take photos
and he even stole the glass eyes from
some of the corpses
which were blind in one eye so they had
a glass eye
and wore the glass eye on his
silver rings that he had on his fingers
what
he had a real thing for dead bodies he
even admitted
in one interview with a magazine called
q magazine in 1990 that
he he liked being with dead bodies but
he denied
as he would being a necrophiliac
he said in an interview that he liked
being around dead bodies
dead people yeah and he also boasted to
some contacts which didn't get into the
media
uh posted to some people who knew him
that he had had sex
with dead bodies what was the context of
that like why would he say that in an
interview that he oh yeah i like hanging
out around
corpses i guess he was talking about
himself his interests and that
one of his interests would be um
because he was known to be helping out a
lot in hospitals he was known to be
raising a lot of funds for hospitals
so the the talk about hospitals probably
led to
him talking about his working at the
hospitals and as a volunteer porter he
would have
also had one of his responsibilities
would be to
transport the dead bodies down to
debauchery
and that probably led to his talking
about
dead bodies and his being
whereas some people would be
uncomfortable being in a mochery or
around their bodies he had the opposite
he
he liked being around them of course he
christ
he wouldn't admit
that he liked sex with dead bodies he
stopped short of that
but but he had mentioned to some people
who
revealed it after he died that he had
had sex with some of the dead
bodies in the mortuary uh
he he was a necrophiliac in fact there
are some nurses who also claimed
that they spied on jimmy savo because he
was a celebrity they want to see what he
was up to and when he wasn't watching
they claimed they spied on him and that
they saw him having sex
with dead bodies so
well as i said you know with satanists
anything goes
and i know from an ex-satanist who used
to go
to uh a certain cemetery with her coven
to do their rituals that satanists are
attracted to dead bodies
they want to get a power from the dead
bodies and they will sometimes try and
access
a newly buried corpse
for their own rituals for their own
purposes which
can include having sex with the dead
body
so you should not be surprised at the
sort of things they get up to in terms
of sexual behavior
not just necrophilia bestiality
sometimes they force their child victims
to have sex with animals
uh this all comes back to the
do whatever you want attitude
the uh the attitude of well
we do not want to have any restrictions
this is our understanding of freedom
we will do whatever we want to do we
will experiment
in whatever way we wish to sexually with
anything
that moves dead or alive um
this is you could say in a way the
logical conclusion of that kind of
thinking
and where it needs to and
so that was it was it's not only several
i would say with
confidence that there was
internecrophilia a lot of satanist
abusers are and
they will especially be attracted to
a cemetery where bodies are still being
buried so then you can get
they they can get the access to
more newly buried bodies uh rather than
a cemetery that for
decades or maybe even 100 years
has not had a new body buried there
that would be less of an attraction to
them unless there's a history
of that cemetery uh being associated
with occultic worship
for example uh they'll have less reason
to hang out there
you've spoken to hundreds of these
victims are these survivors these
satanic ritual survivors
what are some of the stories that you
find are
most common with all of them well there
are many common characteristics
uh one of which is the
satanist wearing dark cloaks and
chanting often in a language they don't
understand
the other common characteristics will
include
being gang raped i'm i'm sad to say
by the satanist uh i know one
one woman who as a child
they would have the what is known as the
black mass or satanic mass
uh in a church that they sneak into at
night
because one of the church members
in fact it was the leader of the church
the vicar at that time who had the key
and was the satanist abuser himself so
he would let in the rest of his covenant
in at about 2 a.m
and they would do their satanic mass
and then the bread they would put human
ashes
baked into the bread and for the
so-called wine they would use blood
and after doing their satanic mass
they would then gang rape her
so can you imagine what it's like for a
child one after another they would they
would
rape her and she knew that i was coming
and she'd be kept in a cage in the
church
while waiting for all this to happen
they love to desecrate churches they
love to desecrate
uh church altars and they love to
defile children and she got
went through all that she went through
hell basically uh
it it's it's a miracle you could say
that she's not
completely broken
it took years for her to heal but she
has made a good life for herself
and she does a very good and responsible
job
but as a child she she was
exposed to all this hellish
abuse by her own parents both her
parents were satanist abusers
and one of the parents was a nurse can
you imagine
a nurse who has so much power
over patience who's actually a satanist
abuser
in reality that is a deeply concerning
thought
uh and uh i said to her you know i
wouldn't want to be
one of your mother's patients that's for
sure uh
but that was um the reality
they were not a rich family so they are
more than like the
working class satanists
okay abusers uh but they
were doing uh a very regular
abuse to her and her brother so they
would force on
a regular basis they were forced uh
usually on the weekend
uh her and her brother to eat feces
and drink urine and on a regular basis
usually on a saturday they would take
her to uh
a pool swimming pool that they would
have private use of they probably booked
it for private use
and they would drown her in the pool
uh and then revive her
but it was like a weekly suffocation
session
that you have uh her grandfather was
also a satanist and he would strangle
her
on a regular basis they they seem to get
off on that
um and uh
this was the life the so-called life she
led for
for years um because she was born into
that family
fortunately by the time she reached her
teens
she was out of it she had suppressed a
lot of the memories because of the sheer
trauma
i